in full costume right now I love it oh
you know what I was I told everyone so
far that yeah I was little late this
morning I had a rough night last night I
woke up I was late for my car uh-huh and
I just I just slipped something on hello
oh my gosh baby group was the big the
big breakout star of the panel oh man
baby Groot just got his own show be
reasonable yeah spit on you guys don't
ya it's already the distinct to that I
think 29 figure ya got your first
glimpse of baby group whose wonderfully
adorable and also a murderer as you see
in the movie and and then we have a big
scene with what we have a sort of teaser
thing special san diego comic-con piece
which featured Fleetwood Mac's the chain
and it has a you know we see first
glimpses of Elizabeth the Vicki as Aisha
is you know chris sullivan his taser
face and of course kurt russell as ego
the Living Planet not to mention
Sylvester Stallone Sylvester still
serious character we don't know yet so
if we would not gonna be on the
soundtrack what can tell me about a
soundtrack well the San we played two
songs we play Fleetwood Mac and we play
jail the Americans come a little bit
closer and there's pretty good chance
both those songs are in the movie okay
baby Groot was uh was the really hit
star of the panel i believe yes is Vin
Diesel's voice gonna be different or are
you a little secret that were we're
holding out on releasing because we
don't know the answer we're figuring it
out exactly how be hilarious if it's
just full deep Vin Diesel I'm dealing
with Ben and I have been dealing a lot
with it we're freaking out exactly the
right way to do it so it's it's taking
some trial and error but we're figuring
it out